sérguei lávrov el jefe de la diplomacia
rusa intenta ganarse a sus homólogos
africanos tras cinco meses de conflicto
en ucrania su estrategia a una gira por
áfrica al mismo tiempo que el propio
presidente francés emmanuel macon se
reúne con diferentes delegados africanos
mientras las tropas francesas se retiran
de malí rusia está ampliando sus
operaciones militares especialmente a
través del grupo paramilitar warner
y francia poco a poco se está quedando
aislada está siendo contrarrestada en
los países que eran sus antiguas
colonias y el pasado mes de abril el
ejército francés hizo públicas estas
imágenes en las que se ven a soldados
del grupo warner enterrando a civiles
cerca de la base de gossip en el norte
de mali describen estas imágenes como
parte de un plan para hacer ver que los
militares franceses dejaron una masacre
antes de entregar el control de la base
a las tropas malienses en el plano
económico rusia acusa a la nación
europea de retrasar la exportación de
cereales desde ucrania
todos somos atacados por algunos que
dicen que las sanciones europeas son la
causa de la crisis alimentaria mundial
incluso en áfrica esto es totalmente
falso simplemente los alimentos y la
energía- se han convertido en armas de
guerra para rusia a pesar de sus
esfuerzos en el continente africano la
presencia económica de rusia es sólo la
mitad de la de francia y 10 veces menos
que la china si no compras capa útil no
sustituirá políticamente a otras
potencias establecidas desde hace tiempo
pero está ganando cuotas de mercado e
influencia política en diferentes países
en 2023 se celebrará una segunda cumbre
rusia áfrica mientras se intensifican
las tensiones políticas entre europa y
rusia que se disputan la influencia del
continente africano